The two things I think you should do to figure out what set does is first do experiments.
This is probably really the most pleasant and the way that most
programmers would want to understand new things.
Experiments are limited though.
If you really want to understand things, you'd probably need to read some documentation as well
or at least look for documents on the web that might give you more insight.
Playing tennis is probably fun and you'll learn something about sets
but a different kind of set than we're using in Python.
For the first choice, well I think the course forums are very valuable
and I definitely encourage you to use them and to take advantage of
other people learning the same things, but it's not a great way to start.
It's really good to try some things on your own before you get
into the course forum and ask for help.